rebecca bonsoir bonsoir patrice des
nouvelles de renault oui maintenant
criait ça fait 8 1 depuis son dernier
album de chansons originales ici divorcé
y est en panne d'idées il va vraiment
pas bien il est déprimé le dit lui-même
mais par contre renault pour plusieurs
personnes avec une importance capitale
on se rappelle d'un gros guardian le
jeune gouagnon engagé énervé elop
d'accord que revenu un peu prisonnier ou
version vraiment et peut-être que pour
combler à cette absence médiatique on a
choisi de faire un album hommage aux
artistes se sont réunis ça s'intitule la
bande à renault et renault sont très
investis dans ce projet on écoute celle
qui se débrouillent le vieux etc car de
pirates avec mistral gagnant m'asseoir
sur un banc c'est minutes à licques toi
et regarder les gens tant qu' on en a
parlé
guy moreau qui reviendra en serrant la
main tu es petit doigt alors je vois
qu'il ya aussi carla bruni oui qui n'ont
dressé
nicola sirkis mais quand il sort tout
son univers des déchets
grand corps malade grand corps malade a
préféré qui lui sont très inspirés qui
est très solennelle est quatrième à
médailles ne pleure plus mon père je
vise au fil de l'eau
regardez votre enfant il est parti m'a
je sais c'est pas marrant mais c'était
mon destin est ce qu on attend aussi
ghilas gens sont déçus et n'ont ni miss
maguy ni morgane de toi ce qui veut donc
vainqueur est probablement un volume 2
qui va sortir sa fureur de la génération
bodmer commis en france à ne pas
l'aborder très bien pour un ok
maintenant oui à quoi
jack white que j'adore vous connaissez
jack white des white stripes dit j'adore
c'est pas vrai a toujours prouvé mais
tout le monde connaît le meilleur sur
des white stripes seven nation army
peut-être pu se remettre annonce oui
donc c'était le méga succès des whites
jack white est quelqu'un qui a longtemps
cultivé le mystère qui surprend qui
étonne à chaque fois qui peut être un
peu excentrique un peu plus d'un an et
qui revient avec un deuxième album solo
intitulé là j'arrête au plais s'affaisse
sonne comme une traînée
bon c'est du blues rock mais il est
obsédé par le blues rock et le punk mais
c'est un gars comme beaucoup ici tout ce
qui est authentique puisque sincère et
c'est alors là oui il est vraiment du
pain c'est costaud ces turbulences et
souper c'est généreux c'est vraiment
très bon et tout sera moral élevé tête
d'un petit festival osheaga deux ou
trois chaque fois on reparle de notre
chronique oui on se quitte avec kevin
parent a changé depuis qu'avec parents
qui les lance un nouvel album c'était un
peu une surprise et de son propre aveu
c'est un album de gaga alors on fait
avec ce jeu là bas mais tu dis pas ça
un saut
c'est sûr
jeudi m